la geometría está presente en cualquier
lugar vamos a ubicar algunos cuerpos y
figuras geométricas en estos edificios y
objetos que nos rodean a diario
en estas imágenes podemos ver prismas
pirámides esferas y mucho más pero cómo
saber cuál es cuál muy fácil cada figura
tiene características únicas
los cuerpos geométricos tienen tres
dimensiones y se componen por figuras
geométricas veamos las tres dimensiones
de un envase de leche alto ancho y largo
este envase se llama prisma rectangular
porque tiene forma de rectángulo
ahora conozcamos las partes de un cuerpo
geométrico estas son caras
arista y vértice la cara se refiere a
todas las superficies planas
por ejemplo aquí tenemos un dado y su
nombre como cuerpo geométrico es cubo
el cubo tiene seis caras que en este
caso las podemos contar fácilmente
porque cada una tiene una cantidad de
puntos por cada uno dos tres
4 5 y 6 caras las aristas son las líneas
o lados que unen las caras de un cuerpo
geométrico en la parte superior del cubo
tenemos 4 aristas porque estas líneas
unen a esta cara con otras en la cara
del lado derecho tenemos una más 2 y 3
del lado izquierdo tenemos otras tres y
hay otras de los lados que ya no
alcanzamos a ver tenemos una dos y tres
veamos la última parte de un cuerpo
geométrico el vértice el vértice es el
punto donde se unen tres o más aristas
veamos nuestro cubo
aquí tenemos un vértice aquí otro aquí
uno más
y tenemos ocho vértices en este cubo
como te das cuenta cada punto es la
unión de tres aristas
ayúdame identificar los elementos
anteriores en la siguiente figura es el
vídeo para resolverlo y después continúa
viéndolo para comparar tus respuestas
perfecto en la letra tenemos un vértice
en la letra b una arista y en la letra c
una de las caras
hasta el momento los cuerpos geométricos
que más revisados se llaman poliedros
porque tienen sus caras planas pero
estoy segura de que también has visto
algunos cuerpos geométricos que pueden
tener algunas partes curvas como los
cilindros los conos las esferas o semi
esferas a este tipo se les llama cuerpos
geométricos redondos conozcamos un poco
más sobre ellos
el cono tiene una cara que funciona como
base y otra que le da la forma redonda
sólo tiene un vértice y una arista el
cilindro tiene dos bases en forma de
círculo que funcionan como caras planas
y la tercera cara es redonda tiene dos
aristas que están aquí y no tiene
vértices la esfera solo tiene una cara
redonda no tiene vértices ni tampoco
aristas la semiesfera es un cuerpo
geométrico que tiene una vista dos caras
y cero vértices ahí se me estaba
olvidando un cuerpo geométrico llamado
autora mejor conocido como 'don a este
cuerpo tiene una cara y no tiene ni
aristas ni vértices ahora que ya conoces
las principales características de los
cuerpos geométricos te invito a
reconocerlos en todo lo que te rodea ya
sea en tu casa o en la escuela